allez c'est l'heure à présent de notre
module on va plus loin
[Musique]
on va plus loin comme chaque soir à
20h40 heures de Paris on vient ensemble
sur deux infos marquantes de la journée
en compagnie ce soir de nos chroniqueurs
Bruno Darou de la rédaction de France 24
bonsoir Bruno bonsoir
rédacteur en chef à Afrique Magazine
bonsoir Ziad merci à tous les deux de
m'accompagner pour ce on va plus loin on
va plus loin ce soir tout d'abord sur
l'ouverture en Guinée on en parlait il y
a quelques minutes du procès du massacre
de Conakry du 28 septembre 2009 au moins
156 morts à l'époque des milliers de
blessés de terribles exactions dans la
répression brutale d'une manifestation
de l'opposition interdite par le
capitaine Dadis camarade alors à la tête
de la jungle manifestation qui avait
pour objectif de le dissuader de se
présenter à la présidentielle
aujourd'hui sur le bon des accusés 11
personnes dont l'ex-che chef de la
jointe 600 parties civils dans ce procès
écoutez tout d'abord asmao Diallo
présidente de l'Association des victimes
des parents et des amis du 28 septembre
nous voulons vraiment la vérité nous
voulons
qu'il y ait des réparations nous voulons
une reconnaissance nationale pour toutes
les victimes des abeilles
et nous espérons avoir une justice
claire
transparente pas de parodie de justice
et en présence de tous ceux qui ont été
inculpés dans ce dossier alors tout
d'abord Bruno pour revenir un peu sur
les faits de 2009 des crimes d'une
violence inouïe avait été commis oui
absolument alors on est donc le 28
septembre 2009 il y a une grande
manifestation de l'opposition des
dizaines de millions de partisans de
l'opposition qui veulent s'opposer à la
candidature annoncée de Moussa Dadis
Camara à l'élection présidentielle qui
est alors à la tête de la junte qui a
dit pendant des mois qui n'étaient pas
véritablement intéressés par le fait
d'être candidat ou pas candidat il l'a
dit d'ailleurs à plusieurs médias dont
France 24 et qui finalement décide de se
porter candidat à la présidentielle donc
ça provoque un fort mouvement
d'opposition on est donc avec plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de partisans qui se
réunissent au stade de Conakry et c'est
là que les choses dérapent de manière
absolument terrible avec des membres de
la garde présidentielle assez nombreux
qui interviennent et qui vont quand même
procéder un véritable massacre puisqu'il
y aura au moins 156 morts plus de 109
femmes violées il y aura des exactions
des centaines de disparus donc voilà un
bilan absolument épouvantable et qui
sait les exactions se sont poursuivies
dans les jours qui ont suivi donc ça a
été véritablement un événement
traumatique quand même pour la Guinée
que ces événements du 28 septembre 2009
le stade sera d'ailleurs renommé stade
du 28 septembre
pourquoi est-ce qu'il s'ouvre seulement
13 ans après les faits
on va partir de la bonne de la bonne
explication c'est qu'il fallait bien que
un moment ça arrive et peut-être qu'il y
avait une conjonction politique qui fait
que le procès peut se tenir aujourd'hui
depuis les exactions il y a eu des
enquêtes il y a eu l'intervention du
système des Nations Unies il y a eu la
CPI il y a eu la période
avant la prise du pouvoir par le leader
de la transition
Doumbouya il y a eu la période Alpha
Condé dont on dit qu'il était pas
partisan d'avoir quelque chose de
d'ouvert donc on sent bien j'étais pas
dans le palais à côté de lui mais il y a
quand même des enjeux politiques très
importants derrière ce procès puisque
Moussa Dadis Camara par exemple reste
quelqu'un d'assez pas populaire mais qui
a certains appuis en Guinée qui est un
leader de la Guinée forestière qui a
toujours un parti politique qui s'était
d'ailleurs rapproché récemment
du colin Doumbouya donc tout ça joue
mais il y a un moment où je pense que
les planètes s'alignent et que peut-être
aussi pour le régime actuel il faut
faire justice mais peut-être aussi
faut-il se débarrasser après tout d'un
certain nombre de gens qui sont encore
assez comme je vous l'ai dit assez
influent et peut-être aussi faut-il
donner une image de
quand même à enjeu élevé et qui sera
suivi de très près notamment dans le
cadre de la lutte contre les exactions
de la part de jeunes militaire et aussi
et c'est très important contre les
violences faites aux femmes
il y a une l'histoire contemporaine en
Afrique et
à écrire encore il y a pas eu il y a pas
très longtemps il y a eu le procès
Blaise Compaoré en son absence le procès
de du meurtre ou de l'assassinat Thomas
Sankara
il y a eu une tentative d'explication là
j'espère qu'il va y avoir ce que veulent
les victimes c'est savoir quelle était
la chaîne de commandement c'est pour ça
que le personnage de Dadis Camara est
très important parce qu'il est président
à ce moment-là mais est-ce que c'est lui
qui a donné les ordres est-ce que ça a
été fait en dehors de lui mais il est
chef de l'État donc il assume une
responsabilités
de de personnalité dont certaines
étaient même encore ministres sous Alpha
Condé
il y a le la personne qui a essayé de le
tuer d'ailleurs
que je crois s'appelle Toumba Diakité
enfin il y a tout tout un aéropage de
gens qui exercait des responsabilités
opérationnelles dans le pays le ministre
de la Santé l'ex-mise la santé est
inculpé par exemple parce que il n'a pas
cherché à
sauver les gens qui étaient dans le
stade où aller soigner donc c'est le
système qui est mis en cause mais pour
les victimes c'est qui a donné l'ordre
pour les victimes c'est qui va nous
indemniser pour les victimes c'est
écrire l'histoire et puis il y a les
gens qui ont été tués par balle les
manifestants et puis à l'aspect
spécifique aux femmes qui est
extrêmement important et je pense que ça
la présenter hier un rapport qui réclame
une meilleure prise en charge des
victimes de viol en Guinée et l'adoption
une urgence d'une loi sur les violences
le viol est une arme de guerre un peu
partout mais c'est une arme de guerre en
Afrique
on peut parler du con de la RD Congo on
peut parler de la Guinée c'est c'est si
on peut faire remonter cette cette
violence contre les femmes et la poser
devant un tribunal c'est pour ça que je
vous dis il y a l'aspect politique il y
a probablement des choses très complexes
et un peu magouilleuses derrière tout ça
mais il y a aussi quelque chose de
majeur sur le plan de l'exemple s'il
mène ce procès jusqu'au bout ça peut
être c'est aussi une manière pour les
autorités de polir un peu leur image oui
alors après normalement le procès va se
dérouler de manière autonome par rapport
aux autorités mais le fait d'organiser
ce procès dans ces conditions-là
effectivement est une manière pour elle
peut-être de polir leur image mais quand
même une des questions essentielles
parce qu'il faut quand même rappeler que
Moussa Dadis Camara il a toujours dit
qu'en fait il n'était pas responsable il
n'était pas le commanditaire de ce qui
avait été commis et son explication qui
va sans doute être examiné de très près
pendant ce procès c'était qu'en fait
l'armée guinéenne était absolument
incontrôlable il a eu ça a été diffusé
aujourd'hui sur France 24 notamment une
phrase lors d'une interview dit vous
comprenez une armée ou un caporal peut
dire merde je cite je veux dire merde à
un colonel il y a pas il y a pas de
respect de la hiérarchie donc tout ça en
gros est parti en vrille si vous passez
l'expression et moi j'étais absolument
pas au courant donc ça c'est sa ligne de
défense et c'est ça notamment qui va
être quand même examiné parce que si il
est avéré à l'issu de ce procès que
c'est lui qui a donné des instructions
notamment aux membres de sa garde
présidentielle pour aller tirer sur des
civils des femmes des manifestants de
l'opposition évidemment ça va changer le
cours et la nature du procès alors autre
thème on va plus loin ce soir les
soupçons de sabotage sur les gazoduc
Nord Stream reliant la Russie à
l'Allemagne en mer Baltique après que
c'est gazoducs ont donc été touchés tous
deux par des fûts inexpliquées la Russie
est pointée du doigt par les Occidentaux
mini tout implication alors
là on en est toujours au stade des
soupçons bien sûr Bruno impossible
d'être certain en tout cas à qui profite
la situation
c'est une bonne question à shred mais ce
sort bien difficile de le dire puisque
on est dans une véritable guerre
informationnelle chacun se renvoie la
balle et désigne évidemment l'adversaire
comme étant responsable de ce qui est
quand même ça c'est une certitude un
sabotage puisque vu aussi
dit que c'est un sabotage
d'une réunion du Conseil de sécurité qui
normalement devrait avoir lieu vendredi
et elle demande même aux Américains de
dire s'ils sont responsables s'ils sont
impliqués dans cet acte de sabotage
aggravé donc c'est la seule chose sur
laquelle tout le monde est d'accord
c'est que c'est un acte de sabotage il
faut savoir donc quand même que ce
gazodique Nord Stream
était encore en activité même si depuis
début septembre les Russes avaient
invoqué des problèmes techniques donc
des questions de maintenance pour
interrompre les livraisons qui se
poursuivaient malgré tout et qui
servaient aux pays européens à remplir
leur cuve en quelque sorte pour passer
l'hiver avant d'arrêter les importations
de gaz russe donc déjà ce
gazoduc était à l'arrêt en fait mais
plein de gaz depuis début septembre et
donc il y a eu plusieurs explosions et
des fuites de méthane qui est
extrêmement dangereux qu'ils vont sans
doute se poursuivre dans les jours à
venir savoir que le méthane est un gaz
plus dangereux que le CO2 sur
l'environnement
de tonnes de gaz et le méthane est
extrêmement dangereux quoi mais
d'abord techniquement c'est pas si
simple de d'aller faire sauter des des
pipelines qui sont à des profondeurs
j'ai vu des chiffres un peu différents
nous mais disons une centaine de mètres
de profondeur avec des des constructions
très épaisses donc c'est quand même il
faut du matériel il faut des des espèces
de petits des petits robots qui
pourraient descendre qui seraient pas
détecté enfin il y a quand même beaucoup
beaucoup de mystères sur le plan d'une
possible opération et il y a beaucoup de
possibilités alors évidemment tout le
monde se tourne vers la Russie parce
qu'on se dit que ça serait une manière
de rendre ces pipelines totalement une
opérationnelle pour des mois puisqu'il
faudrait les réparer mais bon toute la
complosphère mais pas complètement
complet parle d'une possibilité
américaine parce que les Américains
étaient fortement opposés assez
pipelines et à l'implic et à la mise
sous tutelle en gros de l'Allemagne
aussi sur le plan énergétique donc on va
voir ce qui se passe mais ce que ça
souligne c'est l'extrême fragilité de
l'Europe sur la question énergétique
c'est-à-dire on a pas de ressources on a
le pré on a le nucléaire on a le
nucléaire donc on a le nucléaire qui
pose une discussion politique un peu
partout mais s'il n'y a pas de nucléaire
et si les pipelines ne fonctionnent pas
on est à sec et quand on dit on est à
sec c'est pas une vue de l'esprit c'est
on est à sec les usines s'arrêtent le
chauffage s'arrête l'électricité
s'arrête tout s'arrête et donc les
pipelines existant aujourd'hui donc par
exemple ceux qui viennent d'Algérie dont
on parle pas mais qui pourrait
parfaitement être des cibles celui qui
traverse le Maroc et qui va vers
l'Espagne le nouveau qui est entre la
Norvège et la Pologne tous ces toutes
ces infrastructures en cas de en cas de
guerre chaude non déclaré mais où on
pourrait s'amuser à faire sauter des
trucs ça devient des actes de guerre
réelle concernant l'Europe qui serait
réellement mise à sec et ça c'est c'est
une vraie préoccupation parce que
effectivement les les gazoducs sont très
difficiles à sécuriser ça ça permet des
bateaux partout 100 m parfois ça s'étend
sur là le North stream et deux qui n'est
jamais ent au service enfin c'est sur
1000 km donc c'est extrêmement difficile
à surveiller et d'ailleurs il y a un
autre pays européen qui est très inquiet
et les autres pays européens sont très
inquiets aussi c'est justement la
Norvège qui a un peu pris le relais dans
l'urgence en partie avec d'autres pays
effectivement notamment comme l'Algérie
et mais il faut savoir par exemple juste
deux chiffres la Russie avant la guerre
envoyée à l'Europe en quelque sorte 150
milliards de mètres cubes de gaz
aujourd'hui la Norvège c'est 122
milliards de mètres cubes de gaz par un
gazolu qui part de la Norvège et après
qu'il y a des ramifications dans les
pays européens si ce Gazo du clat
connaît les mêmes mésaventures que North
TRIMA là ça aura des conséquences
vraiment très graves pour l'ensemble des
économies européennes dans les semaines
à venir mais c'est déjà la fin on va
plus loin merci ziade merci Bruno
d'avoir participé et pour vos éclairages
restez avec nous la suite de Paris
direct c'est dans quelques minutes
[Musique]